i'm anirudh shah i'm a research engineer
at iggy and today i'll be talking about
building better models with location
data
so quick overview of the talk
we'll start with like a use case an
example to couch the token and we'll
come back just a few times
then we'll give an overview of
geospatial data
and geospatial boundaries then we'll
have a demo of how to use iggy and
geospatial data for like a use case
which is the example that we're giving
in the first part
um then we'll talk about feature
insights that we found through some
internal modeling of our own and finally
like a little sneak peek on graph
machine learning with geospatial data
which something we just started doing
but i'm very excited about
so firstly this use case
we are building a vacation rental
recommender system
and we have user data um on previous
rentals they visited and also some data
about those rentals and we want to
recommend rentals for a user's upcoming
trip to austin
this person is on our site searching for
austin and we have some profile data on
them they're in their mid-30s and
they're traveling with a group of
friends
and we think that geospatial data will
enable us to give better recommendations
to them so we want to integrate that
data into our system
so firstly what is geospatial data
at iggy we think of geospatial data as
what is nearby
and this includes things like points of
interest
which are bars restaurants museums
parking lots
schools
water bodies social economic data park
data and much more
and for our use case recommender system
the kind of features we may want to
include what are the nearby restaurants
to each property the nearby parks and
recreation areas rivers and lakes etc
and so what data sets can be enriched
with geospatial data
any data with a location column and this
might be a latitude longitude address
zip code
and there are examples of this kind of
data across industries real estate
travel marketing
public health
it's very flexible
in the next few slides i'll give some
examples of some tables that can be
enriched with geospatial data to give
you some context
so first we have
this is city bike locations in austin
like rental locations as you can see
there's an address column so we can
enrich this with geospatial data
this is a data set about area
deprivation index which is a socio
economic indicator and again we have a
zip code column so we can enrich it
and this data set is what we'll actually
use in our demo which is the vacation
rentals as you can see each row is a
different vacation rental and we have a
latitude longitude so again we can
enrich the geospatial data
so why isn't geospatial data widely used
in machine learning it's difficult and
the key pain points that we have
identified through our own experience
and through talking to customers around
data engineering so firstly you have
sourcing and acquisition right
you may not be able to get good quality
water data from the same place you can
get good quality points of interest data
and because of this you're analyzing and
evaluating many different sources
aggregating them and they may come in
different formats
so that's one challenge the another
challenge is cleaning and quality checks
right
sometimes the data is mislabeled you
know we've seen data that
because it had the word lucky in it was
labeled as a casino but actually you
know lucky could be a bar restaurant
something else
so you have to go through and clean that
kind of data that might be missing data
so that's a challenge
another challenge is computation
normalization let's say you want to
calculate catchment areas across the
whole country based on the road networks
that's a lot of compute
and finally engineering and delivery you
have to deliver this data in a form
that's easily accessible for machine
learning pipelines and that's the
non-trivial task as well
so next we'll talk about geospatial
boundaries
so to us at iggy a geospatial boundary
is any geographic area over which data
is aggregated and you have
administrative boundaries like metro
area census block group census tract zip
code and then you have derived
boundaries
and one that we think is very powerful
is an isochrone 10 minute walk
what this is it's a polygon around a
location and everything within that
polygon is within 10 minutes walk off
that location
and this is how we believe humans
interact with the surrounding
environment
traditionally in this kind of field you
did catchment areas based on a straight
radius as you can see in that image as
the crow fly radius you might have a
half a mile radius and a circle around
the property and this doesn't take into
account whether you're crossing a river
you know going over a highway that kind
of thing and so we think this is loses
some of the detail the nuance in the
area
this image is the isocrates as you can
see much more irregular but much more
natural in terms of how we think about
space and movement
on the next few slides i'll kind of give
an example of why we think the isochrone
is also a very powerful boundary for
modeling and gives you more detail than
a zip code since it's block group so
you'll be seeing some maps of austin
segmented by different boundaries and
then shaded and the shading will be the
number of points of interest within that
boundary
so this is downtown austin
split into zip codes and the shading
tells you the number of points of
interest within each zip code now the
two white dots there
are two properties that we're going to
compare through this sort of walkthrough
and they're both in the same zip code so
if you aggregated at this boundary they
both have the same feature and they
would come out the same from this
context
from a census block group con context
you know it's better they're smaller so
you get more nuance but again for our
use case these two properties in the
same senses block group
so they have the same feature values
but now if you look at isochrone in 10
minute walk you start to see the nuance
in how the city has been developed
the one to the east is closer to
downtown there's many more points of
interest within a walking distance off
that property the one to the west is
stuck between a highway so it's pretty
unaccessible and so if you modeled it
with using the isochrone boundaries you
can get this detail in your model and in
your predictions
so now we'll do a little demo of how
we use geospatial data icky and the use
case around travel
in this demo we will demonstrate how to
build a vacation rental recommended
system a very simple one
using iggy and geospatial data
so the first step is to import some
libraries
and then we'll load a rental data set
which is
a will be a data frame where each row is
a different property and then there's
some mess data associated with that
property in the columns
so we load that
and then we load
iggy geo spatial data and then we enrich
this rental data set with the geospatial
data
and that's very easy to do we've built
this python iggy enrich package
and when we run the cell
we end up with this enriched data frame
which will be our vacation rental data
frame enriched with the geospatial data
um
and that's what we used to do our
analysis downstream
and so as mentioned in the use case we
had a user that we're targeting here is
someone in the mid-30s who's traveling
with a group of friends and that's the
profile that we have
and so
we
have used uh sort of domain knowledge to
say
users with that profile there's some key
features that they care about for
example
the number of crossfit gyms within a 10
minute walk of that
property
the number of restaurants per square
kilometer
and the median age of the census block
group that that property is in
so we'll just subset this in
total enriched data frame on these
features that we have selected
next step is to filter the data further
um this person has been searching for
properties that accommodate four people
and they also would like to stay for
three nights so we need to filter our
properties based on those criteria
then we process and scale the data
and
now we get to the recommendation part as
i mentioned it's a very simple system so
we're just going to calculate
similarities between different
properties
and then we know that this person has
visited austin and stayed in this rental
409 56278 last year and they gave it a
great review
so
we'll just select
the five most similar rentals to this
rental they've already stayed in and
that's what we recommend to them
so we calculate similarities
we select the top five most similar
rentals
and we end up with a stage frame
of the original rental from last year
and the five most similar rentals based
on the features that we selected and the
vacation rental
mess data
and now we'll just plot this on a map so
we can visualize it better
as you can see we end up with this map
where of austin
the vacation rental that they see in
last year is down here
and
then four of the five recommended ones
are also close by
and then we have this other one up here
to the north which is also recommended
to the user
and if we zoom in
based on the features we selected in
terms of crossfit gyms restaurants etc
it makes sense that we're close to
downtown um
and four of the five are quite close to
each other and the four of the five also
very close to the original the rental of
interest so
you know the visualization gave us a
quick gut check
on our recommendation system and it
seems to make sense
may have been a bit small but that demo
is also available on our website if you
want to go play around with the notebook
yourself
so now we'll just talk about some
feature insights we've done some
internal modeling with our data for
different use cases around real estate
and travel
and we found some interesting things
when you incorporate geospatial data
into these kind of
tasks so in the real estate realm
the use case here is we're predicting
sales price for properties
and our data is property metadata
and then that's going to be enriched
with geospatial data and we saw a two
percent lift in test set performance
with geospatial features and this is you
know very we could have tuned it further
you may see different performance with
different models but this is sort of one
um result that we found
and the key geospatial features that
showed up in our analysis
were things like whether a coast
intersects
with a 10-minute ice cream around a
property
the number of education centers number
of gyms and then the negative impact
which was a number of manufacturing
facilities within that 10 minute
radius which makes sense
and the key property features again you
know this makes sense intuitively square
footage the floor finish and the
interior finish so
this is kind of insights into the key
features in this this particular task
and finally this is a little sneak
preview like i said of something that
i'm very excited about graph machine
learning and geospatial data
so there are many ways to represent this
type of geospatial data graphically this
is one example
that we've started playing with
so in the middle and the node
here 19103 is a zip code
in philadelphia and the nodes with edges
to this middle node are the names of
points of interest
cvs chipotle etc
and then each of these names of points
of interest have another node with an
edge to it which is a poi type
restaurant pharmacy grocery store and so
this is one way of representing that
tabular data and representing the
relationships between different entities
and how might we use these graphical
forms
um the first way we're thinking about is
quality control you know we ingest this
data and it's already tagged by the poi
type
and sometimes it's incorrect as i
mentioned in the challenges with
geospatial data
so we could build a node classification
model on top of this representation to
predict the poi type for each of the
pois in our data set and it will show up
you know where is the discrepancy
between the incoming label and what we
predict
another method another thing that we're
playing around with is representation
learning um one use case here is you
could embed this zip code based on the
pois and the zip code and then compare
embeddings between different zip codes
let's say you wanted to recommend a zip
code that someone should move to based
on where they currently live you could
do that
so that's representation learning and
finally this is such a flexible form of
data that we can incorporate other data
types in satellite imagery
text you know it could be reviews of the
business and these could be node
features and then again we could go back
and do quality control representation
learning with those new features
that's all i had thank you for listening
and
welcome any questions at the end thank
you
[Applause]